hey everyone
welcome
maya
one of the most important words
one of the most important symbols
one of the most important descriptions
of the nature of reality
the more enlightened i become the more i
recognize
that sanskrit
and the upanishads invade us in general
in the teachings of buddha
of adishankara of patanjali
of the advaita vedanta tradition in
general
swami vivekananda sri aurobindo ramana
maharshi nisargata maharaj
they knew
very clearly
let's dive in
maya meaning appearance
illusion magic dream
unreality deception
fraud trick sorcery witchcraft
mystify mirage intoxicate
be lost
that which obscures confuses
and distracts an individual
from god realization
again the theory of maya developed by
adi shankara
over a thousand years ago
indian philosophy
before we continue a little bit more
foundation is that
what is being said by maya
being appearance or illusion or
magic or the
intoxication which is obscuring or
confusing those individuals from god
realizing
is that the nature of our reality
is the diamond necklace that is already
around our neck
as in the very pupil itself is the
observer
which is god which is shared
and the iris is the unique
coloration or the unique expression
of what your individual unit
is contributing that's the source light
that refracts through your unique
diamond slash
jewel around your neck as a unique
experience
and expression
now maya is the
illusion it's the intoxication
of what can be called physicalism
or form
or finity
so those that believe
they are a finite biological creature
egoic contracted energy trapped inside
of a finite body
that don't recognize the eternal
observer and the only way to do that is
to create
the juxtaposition for themselves
between seeking externally
into the waves that are the objects the
thoughts
perceptions sensations beliefs feelings
emotions
in the ocean which is what the observer
is which is what god
is which is then they recognize that
it's the ocean
that is having the experience of the
waves
or another analogy is the sky having the
experience of the clouds
so that massive
cult
of materialism or physicalism
or form or finity
is plaguing
the entire civilization with ignorance
why so few enlightened is because it is
extremely difficult and one must
dedicate themselves
to truth full time for it to yield
for the illusion of maya
to grasp you less and less and for you
to abide more and more in the god
realization
that eternal awareness that is
experiencing
these dreamed creation designs
when you get to that point now you're
really leveling up
now you're really piercing the veilless
veil now you're really god
realizing
otherwise
it's falling for the illusion the
intoxication
of the illusion
definition number one we'll play with
several here to show maya
from all of the different faces
of the mountain
pointing to the one top of maya
and then we're gonna unpack in more
detail below
definition one magic show an illusion
where things appear to be present
but are not what they seem
perfect
definition two that which exists
but is constantly changing and thus is
spiritually
unreal
definition three power or the principle
that conceals the true character
of spiritual reality
maya being the
principle slash power
that conceals god realization
how powerful is that how awakening is
that
how motivating is that that we have
this lineage of sanskrit that teaches us
the profundity
of this word of this symbol
describing the nature of reality so
precisely
so clearly
definition four specifically
with advaita vedanta
the powerful force that creates the
cosmic
illusion that the phenomenal world
is real
do you feel like the phenomenal world
is real do you feel
like the phenomenal world
has a grasp
on you
well you're really gonna like the
upcoming bit on
lakshmi
definition five maya is
also an epithet for the goddess
lakshmi of
wealth fortune
power luxury
beauty fertility
she holds the promise of material
fulfillment
and contentment warning
parable of the prodigal son
that which teases
the individual to become intoxicated
that can be thought of as lakshmi that
wealth
that fortune that power that luxury that
beauty
that fertility the material fulfillment
the contentment just like in the parable
of the prodigal son
seeking externally for happiness
just to hit a breaking point
and turn inward to find
the well of honey consciousness
awareness
which is located under the rock
of the contracted egoic separate entity
definition six the wondrous
and mysterious power to turn
an idea into a physical reality
in many ways this can be thought of as
the dream
in god's brain
just like we go and sleep
for a third of our lives
and during that chunk of time we
simulate these dreams and we immerse
ourselves into the dreams
in first person
as above so below so
god's dream is the idea of
this creation design
this dream this illusion this
maya which has this lakshmi
like grasp on the individual
seeking externally
and we pierce the veilless fail
and we god realize and the grasp
of maya dissolves
bonus
maya is the name of gautama buddha's
mother
you can't write this art any more
beautifully
literally the awakened one buddha
that teaches liberation
from suffering
liberation from maya
that buddha this mom's name
is maya
ridiculous
this is another one of the most
important sanskrit words ever
such a clear symbol that is
describing the nature of reality
leela the divine
play
when i was studying sri aurobindo
around mid 2020
going hardcore full-time truth
i remember him using leela
and i remember looking it up i remember
looking up
maya i remember looking up nirvana
i remember revisiting the pages of
adishankara in patanjali
and i remember over and over again
building up
like a workout
the muscles the strength the
understanding
the conceptual frameworks
that became stronger and stronger over
time
which led to the satori
a little over a month ago
now i really get leela
and everything else in that concept
framework served
that satori and then now
the concepts in that framework become so
much more crystal clear
so lila is the divine play
the cosmic play
the creative activity of god the world
is the stage
and when you understand it as the divine
play this creation design this
earth these inhabitants
are but one creation design
they're but one divine cosmic play
we are eternal this is but one
cosmic play when you begin understanding
that
you begin distancing yourself more and
more from the grasp
of maya of physicalism and you begin
residing and abiding
more and more in the god realization
the seed of the ineffable absolute
impregnates the womb of god
giving birth to infinite maya
what is agentless what is attributeless
what is the ineffable absolute
impregnates god
giving birth to all of the maya
all of the creation designs
all of the dreams all of the illusions
all of the beauty
in them all of the appearance
and to recognize both the non-duality
where there is absolutely nothing to
seek
while simultaneously recognizing
the dualistic concession
which is there is a process of
seeking finding an enlightenment
and to hold both of those is true
simultaneity it's like a flat
mountain
we will be doing more content on that
visualization
soon
god is the magician
we are bonded to illusions
slash delusions
freedom and liberation is understanding
the principles behind
the magic this is leela
the divine play it's as simple as that
enlightenment freedom liberation
is understanding the principles behind
the magic
once you recognize the absolute
once you recognize god realization once
you recognize
the maya of physicalism you win
it's done you're enlightened you're free
of the grasp of the illusion of the
appearance
this simultaneously creates an
effortless action that channels through
you you act as a vessel
for that absolute god
realization to express
itself with the absolute highest
morality in all that one
architects in all that channels through
is architected
solely for the maximizing
of the potential of
the entire civilization the flourishing
the well-being the prosperity and the
abundance of
all of society tackling the biggest
challenges
meeting basic needs
but if one goes seeking externally for
happiness
before the absolute god realization
that's when the breaking points are
reached in planetary ecology
in the perverse incentives in self
dealing
where the ego serves itself
because it doesn't understand that the
other is actually the
self
only the ignorant would ever hurt their
own
body in the sense of hurting
another that would be hurting
the one being it doesn't make any sense
but one has to enlighten to understand
that
purusha this was another one that sri
aurobindo was
passing along to me in mid 2020
that i was
struggling to understand i was doing the
workouts with
understanding and now it makes more
sense
and i will be continuing to learn more
about purusha as well as prakriti
so purusa as in infinite consciousness
as in vidya knowledge
parmenidus was one of the
most famous metaphysicians that's ever
lived
parmenidus said that
very clearly that
the maya itself is an illusion
whereas with prakriti which is
maya which is avidya
which means ignorance so vidya knowledge
of vidya ignorance
and this was very famous by heraclitus
who said ponta ray everything flows
another famous aphorism of his
no man ever steps in the same river
twice
and so the
non-dual tradition
rather than separating into the purusha
and the prakriti the infinite
consciousness and the maya
the parmenidus and the heraclitus the
vidya and the advidia
they bring that all together into just
one
it's not two but in the dualistic
concession here
we recognize there's the maya
that is intoxicating the individual
away from god realization
another one of the main stories that's
used is seeing
a snake at night when it's just a rope
enlightenment daylight clears up
the illusion enlightenment is like dawn
when the darkness of the night maya
is dispelled and you can clearly see
the snake is money the grand illusion
of materialism
this enlightenment is known as
the realization of the soul of things
and turning inward spiritually which
makes outward flow
naturally
there's a rope
at night there's the illusion that it's
a snake
that's maya as dawn comes
enlightenment happens we recognize that
it's simply
a snake excuse me that it's simply
the rope so
upon enlightenment we recognize
that it's just the rope that the snake
was the illusion of maya
super simple explain like i'm five
analogies
for children
and when you truly see the rope
the eternal nature to the absolute
to god realization to the dreams
realities that these are
that is known as the realization of the
soul of
things you get it
you are squandering this life uselessly
in the love of
maya in attachment to maya
they have forgotten god
the diamond necklace around their neck
the well of honey under the rock
being so attached to the intoxication
is exactly what is the forgetting
the an amnesia is the remembering
of god realization
another dualistic concession
is that there is an amnesia that there
is a forgetting that there is this
veilus veil to pierce with remembering
within amnesia
to god realization whereas in the
non-duality there is no two
of there being a forgetting and a
remembering
these things really start clicking and
making
sense once we get to these advanced
stages
the true simultaneity really kicks in
the satori just compounds on itself
come and taste these ultimate
truths it's the seeking impulse
within you it's the truest thing about
you
and that self-realization that god
realization
that is identifying
remembering the diamond necklace around
the neck
that is recognizing the well of honey
under the rock of that contracted egoic
separate entity
nice little stretch nice little dance
a little bit of movement
who is it that is trying to know
and how does he attain brahman
aka what is the
i and how does one attain
the absolute slash ultimate
first ask yourself that question what is
the i
go inward until you discover your source
until you god realize
and that is the attaining of the
absolute slash ultimate
which for this unique diamond
or jewel is its unique expression
of the source light
so to this unit it is
exciting it is the expression
of this unit to
attain the absolute slash ultimate
whereas the expression of other units
could care less
and to truly
realize that
is beautiful
rather than being in the state of
now i must help
everybody become god realized
the creative expression will channel
through
and this unit will architect
great things more great content
great interviews great animated series
great documentaries great anthologies
great
vr pedagogy for god realization
great planetary architectures to
maximize prosperity
yet there is zero attachment there is
zero craving there's zero aversion
and that's what the buddha meant by
being awakened
no craving just
the surrender to the channeling coming
through
for the creative expression that this is
go inward until you realize you are
everything
nothing and even beyond that only when
you know god
will you be fearless and eternal
the everything is taking
on the god realization
of all that is so all of these
creation designs with all of these
observers that are
experiencing them and you take on
the all-inclusive awareness
of all that is of all of those creation
designs and observers
that is god realization at its highest
and then to transcend even the observer
of god is the last thorn
before the absolute
only when you know that will you be
fearless and eternal
that's why laozi said that fear
is the greatest illusion
no path can show you the absolute
you are that already the diamond
necklace
paths only help to remove the veil
that hides truth from our eyes
again the non-duality you are that
already
and then the duality the dualistic
concession
is that these paths help
remove the veil that hides the truth
from our eyes so to god realize
to recognize the diamond necklace
already around our neck
that the source light refracts through
as a unique expression
in the dream of this creation design
cessation of ignorance comes
when one knows that god and i
are one i and my father
are one john 10 30.
it's a perennial wisdom across
all of the spiritual traditions
god and i are one
sri aurobindo said that
the atheist is playing hide and seek
and that the theist saw the shadow of
god and clutched at it
you get a little taste a little glimpse
of the observer
of the witness
of how it's shared
and the individual contracted ego and
its
onion layers become more and more
dissolved
and you're like oh that's it
that's it meanwhile the atheist
is playing games
hide and seek
so the cessation of ignorance comes when
one knows
that god and i are one remember that
that's when the cessation of ignorance
occurs
moksha liberation from suffering
aka identify yourself with god
not with human limitations
the idea that we are bound is only an
illusion
maya freedom is inseparable from the
nature of god
as in the nature of god is freedom
this is ever pure ever perfect
ever unchangeable
god is freedom god is creativity
god is anarchy that's what
these dreams are
free whole
perfect harmonic
anarchic
creativity
simultaneously non-dual while also
the dualistic concession where we see
suffering and well-being and we
architect
civilization towards maximizing
well-being
it's so simple
i love this one yoga
through maya perfects the creativity of
god
yoga in sanskrit means union so we're
are undergoing a union
with god or with the absolute which is
similar to the words hypnosis
or mystic or mysticism
so we undergo a union with god or the
absolute
and we do that through maya
so our union happens through maya
these illusory creation designs
are how we turn back
inward towards
our true nature of god realization
so through maya is how we
pierce that veilus veil and that
perfects the creativity of god
i love that so good
yoga is creative maya plus
gps callback
so union is
creative maya so creative maya of these
dreamed creation designs
is what enables these individual units
to undergo this gps callback
aka union or yoga or hypnosis or
mysticism
to the absolute to god realization
it's unbelievably beautiful
and actually it was bentino massaro who
first introduced
me to the analogy of gps callback
which is such a perfect way to put it
this is like when your drone slash dog
flies slash runs too far away like the
parable of the prodigal son
if you fly the drones nowadays there is
a callback functionality when it flies
too far away
it will come back to you very similarly
with your
dog as it runs too far away there's a
callback functionality
that's the gps callback to the source
the gps callback
to the absolute the gps callback to god
realization
and that's lila this is
the divine play
this eternal divine play
of illusory dreamed maya
and the gps callback
union with the absolute with god
realization with source
very much like the parable of the
prodigal son
so reality is eternal hide and seek
there you go
you might also wonder
well maybe that makes sense why kids
love hide and seek so much
yeah no [ __ ] of course
because they are literally infinity
and they get it it's fun for them
adults are corporate zombies
i am an adult corporate zombie
robot please give me the golden
handcuffs
and pay me my monthly salary so that
i can do the work for you in the
economic machinery
that i don't even love
the more you become enlightened the more
you
are able to recognize the child-like
laughter of the infinite
the child like play wonder ah
bliss peace
that is our true nature
as ramdas said also walking each other
home that's that gps callback
maya is baked into ignorant parenting
this is so good the core curricula of
ignorant parenting
is maya
this one both is so
beautiful that it makes me laugh and cry
simultaneously because we know that
that's the most
upstream problem clearly
ignorant parenting as the child comes
into the world
even at the time of infancy
is being programmed with subscriptions
of separation
subscriptions of ego
and conscious parenting awakened
parenting liberated parenting
enlightened parenting
that's when there are none of those
subscriptions to ego into separation
rather from birth
right away through those first years of
life
the child recognizes itself as
the absolute infinity god expressing
itself
they get it and they get how that is the
illusory
nature of these realities as that
it's locked in from the youth and it's
gigi good game game over they got it
they're self-realized at a very young
age gigi
well played
and so imagine the child births in and
rather than
awaiting like me seeking relentlessly
at 28 being able to write gg
good game well played imagine
them being able to sign that off at age
7
or 12 or 16.
ignorant parenting morphs their child
into an egoic contraction
seeking externally for happiness
oh my gosh this one's also really
mind-blowing
misinterpreting maya as the only
and final reality
the very nature of absolute infinite
god expressing itself
as these dreamed illusory realities
is the only and final reality
and the endless misinterpretation
of that illusion of maya
is ultimate reality
ultimate reality is an eternal
dream
across all of these creation designs
where there's
an endless amount of misinterpretation
of what the nature of those realities
are
and then you get the dude
do gps call back
[Music]
dude
and that's the ultimate reality
that's what these are eternally
and we are also
approaching a fascinating scientific
technological and engineering paradigm
which is enabling us to
wake up to pierce the veilless veil
through these indistinguishable virtual
realities
the better our artificial general
intelligence agi
gets the better our bio and neuro
technology like neural links
get the better our virtual worlds become
more and more indistinguishable
the more and more we will immerse
ourselves into them
as these infinite creative
illusory realities
continuing the cyclical nature
of
absolute infinity god
it's very similar to the source light
refracting
off of the diamond necklace
the source light refracts at the level
of infinity
or absolute to god the source light
refracts again
at the level of god to all of the
creation designs
and the source light refracts one more
time at the
level of all of the individuals
in those creation designs and then it
refracts
one more time for the differentiation
which is through those creative
designed realities that we then
build and that may in fact be
our attractor it may be
what civilization as a decentralized
swarm intelligence is orthogenically
unilinearly architecting towards
that attractor
of that transcension hypothesis of john
smart
and that will be our maya as we immerse
ourselves into those
that will be our maya and we will have
the gps call back
to the absolute infinite god
maya manifests and perpetuates duality
separation affinity
this appearance obfuscates the true
nature of reality liberation
is the breakthrough realization of
invisible
principles
when you speak to somebody that is
egoically
contracted energetically as a separate
biological entity in the illusion
of the dream and you say things like
consciousness is it or awareness is it
that is the observer which is god how
quickly do they have no idea what you're
talking about
including myself several years ago no
idea
and more and more it made sense and then
the
the breakthrough happened satori happens
and that's true liberation because you
recognize the invisible principle
which is that god realization which is
that absolute infinitude
that which we cannot see we do not
believe
we are fools searching from room to room
for what is already
here the diamond necklace rumi
walking on the grounds of great
potential
with no comprehension of ultimate
reality
immersed in the intoxications
of lakshmi of maya
engrossed in them
with
no comprehension of the diamond necklace
already around our neck
maya is the appearance manifestation
of worldly phenomena beautiful so
eloquent
brahman is the cause of maya
the sole metaphysical truth
spiritual truth is true forever
empirical truth is true for now
and that makes sense so much sense in
this framework
the empirical truth of the creation
design
in the dreamed illusion of maya
is true for now
and then the spiritual truth
the ultimate metaphysical truth is true
forever
eternally true that we
are it we are that you are that
i am that the diamond necklace already
around our necks
of awareness of consciousness as god
as the observer as the witness
that is dreaming these creation designs
eternally
there's so much to explore an infinite
amount of exploration to explore
of experiences of fun of
play like leela the divine play
the cosmic play
think like a child and it'll come
more and more play adventure
aw wonder
the more you think like that
wow making these
vocal vibrations that then
go across the planetary
internet into
the observers in those other units
whoa the more you think like that
the more you recognize the ah of just
even this creation design let alone
all of the creation designs and that
spiritual truth is true forever
whereas the empirical truth is true for
now and in the next creation design
there will be an empirical truth that
will be true for now
but the spiritual truth is going to
remain true forever
that's why when dustin deperna was on
our show
on timeless spiritual wisdom
and he was one of the leaders that i
learned with a long dan brown
zolchen
that's why dustin says that
spirituality is the ultimate
it is the ultimate it's what we're here
to do
the gps callback is gonna happen
that seeking impulse is the truest thing
about you
even for people when they turn 60 maybe
it kicks in a little bit and then by the
time they're 80 they die
and they maybe taste a tiny bit as
they die and they recognize oh i'm
eternal
i am the absolute i am the infinite i
am god and they recognize that and
and then there's samsara which is that
cyclical
birthing
and death
so spirituality is the ultimate
non-duality is the ultimate in the sense
that there is nothing to seek
it's just the appearance spirituality is
in a sense
non-duality as well as the dualistic
concession
of their being something to seek
which is enlightenment and undergoing
the process
of finding the diamond necklace that is
already around your neck
maya clouds the inner invisible
principles
spiritual enlightenment is to realize
these
hidden principles maya is the
impermanence of
clouds of experience whereas the
observer the witness the god realization
is the sky
and the sky recognizes the impermanence
of the maya
of the clouds
the net of being indra's net and the net
of illusion
maya are layered in one net
you are both the diamond necklace
already and you are the ignorance
seeking
what is already there
that net of being that indra's net
layered
right on top of the net of illusion of
maya
and that's what true simultaneity is is
recognizing the non-duality
as well as the dualistic concession of
there
being something to seek enlightenment
the net of illusion maya
is thrown over the net of being indra's
net
those that break through the illusion
god realize and vortex
others through
in that dualistic concession to really
hone in on the beep beep beep beep
beep beep beep beep beep beep beep the
gps
call back
that is your key to break through the
illusion to god
realize and then be a vortex
for others to come through
you act as a vortex on the top of the
flat
mountain right flat being non-duality
and the mountain being the dualistic
concession so when you
reach the top when you become
enlightened you act as a vortex
it's very natural because everything you
do
is simply peace it's simply happiness
it's childlike awe and wonder
and architecting only the utmost
well-being
social fabric and people become
gravitated to that
and then they themselves pierce the veil
the veil is fail
so buddha the awakened one is dedicated
to the welfare of
all beings that's what's meant by the
middle way the middle path
or as ramana maharshi said sahaja
samadhi
bringing your meditative consciousness
into society into
the civilizational fabric
this is also the goldilocks zone
this is the tantric path of weaving your
enlightened realizations
into your daily activities
super simple
and that way you avoid the crevices
up the mountain there are crevices if
you've ever seen how people
hike everest there are crevices where
there can be fresh snow
and you won't know and boom you've
dropped 50 feet
to your death the crevices
is when you don't take the middle path
when you don't take
sahaja samadhi the tantric path the
goldilocks zone
the middle way
being dedicated to the welfare of all
beings
naturally god realizing and letting that
channel through
effortlessly effortlessly
effortless action
lautza
buddha is not affected by the illusion
the middle way refutes both eternalism
and nihilism
there is both
the attachment to there being no meaning
nihilism and there's the attachment to
being eternal
eternalism
and to refute both
and we'll get into some of this
complexity at a moment
things like refuting nirvana and samsara
going beyond
even nirvana and samsara going beyond
the cycle of
birth and death and being blown out
enlightened
self is not real dream yet it is real
enough to warrant respecting the world
recognition that maya the illusion the
dream
is not real but it's real enough to
where
it's going to warrant the respecting of
the world
don't overwhelm yourself with capturing
the dream force
aka prana the life force slash wind
which is what the natural expression
is into art
so the wind is the absolute
infinity god expressing itself through
these dreams
and we are that that's the wind
that's prana the life force that's the
no
thing-ness of quantum mechanics all
as energy
yet
becoming
overwhelmed by the process of trying to
capture that wind
that metaphysical ultimate truth and
putting it into art
don't overwhelm yourself in that process
naturally
it's going to come through everything is
naturally going to
channel through as the beautiful
capturing
of that ultimate metaphysical truth into
art and sharing it
voila
the real sky is knowing
that samsara and nirvana are merely an
illusory display
see these types of truths
that are of the highest metaphysical
order
were lost on me six months ago
but now they make crystal clear sense
you're transcending even samsara the
cycle
of birth and death and you're
transcending even nirvana being
enlightened and blown out
the nature of apparent phenomena is
itself
an illusion it's not what it appears to
be
but to know the invisible
leela the cosmic divine play
that's your key
pass beyond things either existing
or not existing beyond
a conception of samsara slash nirvana
for the yogi slash mystic to abide
in the ultimate reality
and that's it the yogi the mystic
hypnosis undergoing union
with the absolute with god is simply an
abiding
in that ultimate reality in those
invisible
forces to know to understand
to recognize
that that is that spiritual truth
that's true forever whereas the
expression
the illusion the maya the dreams these
creation designs with these individual
agents
that that is
the nature of apparent phenomena being
an illusion in itself
and you've recognized that and now
it's just the divine play it's
just the cosmic play it's just leela
and that's when you become a jedi
your flawless graceful
navigation
is just
unbelievable peak
art that's what this is it's peak
art it's peak creativity it's peak
play peak anarchy
peak
expression of
what is the coolest game in town which
is hide and seek
we hide and then we get the gps signal
to seek that seeking impulse
is the truest thing within us
back to our source to consciousness to
awareness to the absolute to infinity
and when we pierce that veilus veil and
we recognize
the diamond necklace around all of our
necks
like an injurious net like in the net of
being
that is refracting that source light
eternally
as unique creative expressions
this has been by far one of my
most clear transmissions
of the nature of reality
i highly recommend re-listening to this
i highly recommend pausing
and taking notes on what resonates with
you most
and reflect on those notes
before you go to bed reflect on those
notes when you wake up
reflect on those notes throughout the
day meditate on those notes
the quality of these transmissions will
continue increasing
and make sure to pause the video and to
take
notes create your own exegesis
this was my exegesis of maya where i
drew out what was most salient
now the same thing goes for you pause
the video
as it most resonates and create that
exegesis for yourself
draw out what's most salient and then
revisit that
several times per day
rather than grabbing the device in the
morning and at night
rather revisit
the most profound notes
and concepts in states of meditative
consciousness
of god realization the more you do that
the more quickly you will break through
the veils fail
and you will also become a vortex in
pulling others through to the god
realization to the absolute to the
infinite
yay this was a fun one i'm glad that it
was
transmitted so surgically and precisely
and i'm also being able to now tell the
difference
between when the transmissions are
really surgical
and really precise versus when they're a
little bit looser
and over time it's going to become more
and more surgical and precise it
requires
to slow down a bit to be able
to really hone in on the most
surgically precise symbol to be
communicated at that exact
moment intuitively
boom that's a wrap on maya
thanks so much for tuning in massively
massively love and appreciate you
so much we are still so
early here with the channel
and with get it the channel right
and with the impact and influence that
it's butterfly affecting
out and so i'm so grateful
thank you thank you and if it brought
you value
like the video subscribe if you haven't
share the video with people that you
know
this will make a profound influence on
do that it's so critical to do that and
also leave a comment
below let me know where you're at
in the process of really
understanding the concepts like maya
across all of these nuances
where you're at in your god realization
in understanding the true nature of
reality
we are announcing
our memberships
to the channel yay
which is exciting there are three tiers
there's the
pupil there's the adept
and there's the sage all with their
exclusive benefits which is really fun
and we'll be using that fuel to just
continue accelerating the goals
and we'll also be continuing to make
sure to disseminate
the highest content absolutely free
for people around the world
it's a core ethos of ours
big love infinite love
leela the divine play
recognize the maya recognize the
illusion
the dream the magic show
and recognize the gps callback
inward to the awareness to the
consciousness to the god realization to
the infinite to the absolute
thank you adore you